the prophet Muhammad s. wasallam told us
whoever builds a mosque for Allah Allah
will build for him a similar house in
jenah and we know the great reward that
will not only be gained but rather will
fill your grave after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives shahada in the Masid
whenever someone learns something in the
Masid yes that will be something that
you will have on your scale
[Music]
how are you guys doing I'm here with the
one and only the
[Music]
champ z z you you were thinking what
joke I can insert here why would I need
to insert a joke when I've got you
manifesting I walked
into personifying you know the idea of a
joke you know on my left how you doing
alul
really been good I think I've been
reading some of your articles um on SJ
news tell us a little bit about SJ news
yeah so s2j news is mashah we've been
covering quite a few articles but
because obviously we don't have to deal
with the whole red tape thing so
alhamdulillah we're able to get free of
charge people can access it right now
yeah and that's why we're struggling
because we're dealing with volunteers
and we don't really have um you know a
strong financially backed team but
alhamdulillah I think we've we we've
covered a lot of stories and one such
story we're going to be talking about
today however before that um there's
obviously news coming out of what's
going on in New Orleans yeah so what are
your thoughts about that yeah well I
mean definitely we're all waiting to see
because we've had a few incidents in the
past where you know people have come out
and we don't know exactly what their
Identity or motives are and I think a
lot of people who are more mature in a
game now um waiting to see exactly what
transpires in terms of this person's m
Etc but what suffice it for me to say is
this it's not
inconceivable that there is an Islamic
terrorist that's not inconceivable thing
there have been many Islamic terrorists
in the course of history we don't we
don't deny that you know we don't deny
that and in fact we condemn that and I
feel like you know if there are two
Extremes in dealing with people who are
Muslims Who come out and do things in
the name of Islam um who which may be NE
negative or wrong one of them is to
completely deny it and one of them is to
uh accept that the reason for it is
Islam these are two extremes uh in this
case we're not really sure um but
suffice it for me to say is that
takfirism and Isis ideology and stuff
like that we've consistently
disavowed um and we've uh We've
challenged head on and in fact I think
that now it's become quite unfashionable
I'm surprised if this does turn out to
be what it is which there's a big
question mark on it let's be honest
because this man was part of the
military this he was part of the mil for
10 years we've seen his LinkedIn profile
we've seen his uh you know his um uh
YouTube videos there's a video of him
talking about he's like selling himself
and stuff like that he doesn't have the
profile of someone who's a tech Fury and
it couldn't have been radicalized as one
could argue in that short space of time
in fact some people are coming out in
the in the communities in Texas and
saying and we didn't even know this guy
he didn't come to the mosque or anything
like that so look there's an argument to
be made either way we'll we're waiting
to see exactly what what transpires but
um whatever this man is we you know weow
him and of course to the families that
are suffering during this time who have
lost people obviously our condolences go
out to you yes and our thoughts um go
out to you as well I mean no one should
be going through this especially during
times of I mean let's face it the New
Year where people are looking towards
the future and things like this happen
so it's it's obviously never good news
but one thing that's very interesting is
whenever something happens pertaining
somebody remotely linked with Islam the
Islamic element is not only emphasized
but there is a dedicated label called
islamism which I don't think any of us
are okay with that we've given the green
flag to islamism as if there's such
thing as Judaism ISM or Christianity ISM
or Hinduism ism there's nothing like
that pertaining other faiths and other
beliefs and other ideologies however
Islam is the only one that has a term
that somehow brings every person that
identifies with Islam to the four and
you can argue that you say islamism is
some kind of political government of
Islam but no but why why include the
word Islam in that yeah because because
a broader term is theocracy right and
obviously that's that's used in they
call it Christian theocracies or Jewish
theocracies or Islamic theocracies but
as you mentioned there isn't like a
dedicated term for any of those things
notwithstanding the fact that there have
been historical examples of all of those
things there have been examples of
Christian states that have been governed
by politics uh in the Christian politics
or there have been Jewish states that
have been governed by Jewish politics so
um I agree with your sentiment I think
that um there's definitely a an emphasis
and a reductive emphasis at that you
know with these things and and you know
what I'll give you a case study of this
it's a story that again we covered on
s2j news.com and this is with regards to
a Jewish group in Guatemala that were
caught doing just just imagine the most
abhorrent crimes you can think of who
are these these are a group known as Lev
tahor okay is this recent this is very
recent okay and the you you've written
an article on this haven't you yeah
we've we've written an article on this
and and this this um what do you this
operation MH was it consisted of 480
Personnel mhm from psychologists to law
enforcements to bro it was a big bro
it's massive it's the biggest that I've
heard so you've got these people that
how many did you say 4 something 480
Personnel needed to do this what was
this thing what they were doing so they
went in and they had to take out 100 60
children really 40 women wow and you
know what they found they found child
abuse
grape forced marriage human trafficking
and they found buried bodies of miners
because they want a Jewish group you're
saying you said this is a Jewish group
Jewish group it's a Jewish group so
isn't this interesting that you've got
in the same week okay where there's an
quote unquote right islamist ATT in New
Orleans and a shameful one at that if
that is what that was um there was a
terrorist attack we we're still waiting
to see exactly what happened but in the
same week that that happened you have
this operation of tremendous proportions
which has been under reported by the
mainstream media in fact before this um
this you know we we started this video I
was looking at the I was looking at a
news report and someone was talking
about you know the woman was saying she
was footing around the idea of
using like Jewish maybe we can put that
in let's see
the60 children were rescued in a police
raid on a fringe fundamentalist Jewish
sect called left deore in Guatemala a
horrific story indeed but certainly not
representative of the Jewish Community
as a whole the the the relationship and
the reputation of the Jewish Community
as a whole do not represent it do not
follow the Jewish
I'm sure that you you all can imagine
the the pr disaster that this is for a
Jewish Community how would you react to
that you seen this this is this is
classic deciphering media 101 this this
is something that should be used as a
case study for people serious about
journalism just look at the way oh yeah
this is I me look at the poor Community
how how must they be feeling I'm sorry
what what about the kids that that were
trafficked and the families who now have
to you know dig out the skulls of those
kids the ones that they've been um
pornography tapes made of those children
what about those no no no the the Jewish
you got to think of the Jewish Community
that's that's what you got to think of
and and they're not all like this here
don't they not they're not all like this
please don't think so don't don't do it
ah but back to those islamism guys the
Muslim and shabaz alhamdulillah
emphasize it and have a picture of a
mosque there have a picture of aik woman
Iran name according to Candace ow she
was saying was Iranian name but here
what his name shabas never heard of an
Iranian my life called shabas God knows
we're seeing bed men covering their head
it's it's a Jewish group they are
following the interpretation of Jewish
law so my question is they're doing yeah
my question is like will you be banning
the Torah will BBC Question Time Nick
arari be debating I didn't see a single
debate about this no I didn't see it not
a single debate yeah it's off the table
it's off the table it's it's just not
being bought up yeah because oh um there
there was an article I saw on um this is
a Jewish Chronicle headline by Melanie
Phillips and she goes if you support the
Palestinian cause in any form you're
facilitating Jew hate oh my God oh my
God this is in the Jewish Chronicle
doesn't get more simpler than that
what's her name Melanie Phillips and
then it goes on to the governments of
Canada the UK
Australia have been some of the worst
offenders is this is this she she put
let's talk though down there is she open
that up for discussion who cares that's
the headline that's in bold mhm and
she's she's she's thinking like what
else can I label as anti-Semitism but
but but this is the problem so anyone
who comes out saying this that's that's
the Palestinian cause imagine if you're
talking about the Torah you're talking
about the talmud you're talking about
about the sort of stuff that's written
in there bro I mean I I don't understand
look look I agree with this sentiment of
course we all agree with the sentiment
you cannot paint the group based upon
the actions of a few obviously and we're
not saying that that's the case here but
what we're saying is that look at the
disparity yeah why is the same way
Muslims are reported not the same way
that Christian Hindu
all Jewish extremists are being reported
why is the word extremist not being used
here because point I think the
manipulation of language there's no Lang
forget manipulation of language there is
no language the words not even there
what's been manipulated yeah yeah yeah
no I think you've made you've made the
case in a very strong way and I think uh
people would be I think now alert to
this fact and people are waking up
people are waking up you have an
operation really and truly let's let's
call it what it is you have an operation
that has you know 500 people almost
participating in it yeah and you have
another thing that took place with one
person you have something organized
longitudinal or you can say longevous
something happening for a very long time
and then you have on the other hand
something that looks like it just happen
quite
sporadically and one and one is taking
precedence in terms of uh news coverage
over the other and this this is exactly
with the study from Georgia State
University uh exemp ified and uh brought
to the four which is that Muslim Islamic
terrorists anything to do with this
religion get four and a half times more
coverage than other religious adherence
or people of different political
philosophies yes well well that's good
that you brought that up guys with that
we will
conclude the prophet Muhammad s wasam
told us that when the son of Adam dies
all of his Good Deeds are interrupted
they are finished except for three
things a continuous charity and a
beneficial knowledge and also a a
righteous offspring that makes Dua for
him your brothers and sisters in Islam
net from Norway are establishing a Masid
a DA Center and fulfilling a great
portion of this Hadith on your behalf
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do whenever someone
prays there whenever someone gives Shah
in the Masid whenever someone learns
something in the Masid yes that will be
something that you will have on your
scale so give generously and Allah will
give you even more